from a timing standpoint let me let you
said something that i actually totally
agreed with and i just kind of want to
push it back to you you said you know
it's speculation and you know three
years is a long time away
and he brought up the tom brady analogy
so i'm gonna throw a sports analogy your
way you tell me if i'm right i'm wrong
and then you respond
you know bill belichick would always say
like listen we're just focused on the
next game i'm not trying to you know i'm
not looking down the road i know we're
playing uh you know the rams two weeks
from now but right now we got the bills
coming up next week so i'm gonna focus
so clearly desantis
you know in november
ten months from now
he's got an election coming up he this
the people of florida will either
re-elect desantis i probably think they
will go for him or they're to choose
something else
so clearly the next game up is running
for governor but once he wins that and
it becomes apparent like all right this
guy's he's in here i think the fodder
will only get deeper like people started
talking about midterms
the day joe biden was elected so like
two years is down the road i get it but
next thing you know holy [ __ ] it's 20 22
or january and midterms are literally
coming up and he's getting uh you know
he's getting coming for election so
i guess do you understand
the fodder especially when it will pick
up after he gets reelected look i
absolutely understand i just feel that
it's overblown because like i'm working
in the office in tallahassee in the
capitol right and i work with governor
desantis and i see what he's doing every
day it's like you know i'm telling you
about november but even sometimes
thinking next week is crazy because
different
like momentous things happen every day
in a huge state like florida with 22
million people and growing um you know
with the covid pandemic and with all the
challenges that we face with the economy
there are so many different crises and
different issues that he has to manage
just on a day to day right like that
even thinking 10 months from now even
thinking about november that isn't even
his top priority of course like he wants
to get reelected but the best way to get
reelected is to do a good job as
governor do a good job in the job that
you're doing yeah and i believe that's
what he is focused on so like when
you're saying his his phone might be
blowing up with like i'm sure people
speculate i mean maybe maybe not i don't
know but um but that just isn't his
focus what he's focused on is is what
he's doing for our state which is an
extremely demanding job and takes up a
lot of time
yeah i i don't disagree like you know
even if you look at 2018 the florida
guber uh
you know the the election that took
place for the governor you had ron
desantis got four 4 million 76 000 votes
and you got andrew gillum that got 4
million 43 000 votes wasn't a run-up
like that was a close race that took
place yeah very close so how do you feel
you scroll to the see what florida looks
like by the way just from a color
standpoint
okay and florida would have been
drastically different had andrew gillum
got elected i mean he was he was almost
like a gavin newsom california this was
obviously before covet hit and and
everything would have been different
yeah 2018. uh people love florida
because of what desantis did with covet
that was this moment to shine yeah
imagine if andrew gillum had been
elected we would be another california
or new york it would be
100 180 but you know when you make that
point so here's what it comes down to
okay
there is a
there's a you said 22 million there's 22
million people that
don't want him to run for president they
just don't you know what i'm saying they
want him to say why would you run for
president just relax governor is great
it's one of the biggest economies in the
world why would you want to be president
just stay chill and the people who are
saying that are the people who live in
florida because they love this guy right
minus the few people that would like
more masks on top of masks and would
like you know mandates on top of
mandates but for the most part people
love florida i mean even aoc loves
florida right right yeah aoc eric
swalwell yeah gretchen whitmer governor
of michigan like all these lockdown like
politicians are coming here on vacation
who can blame them yeah who can blame
them i mean i think the aoc is smart for
this to for the one decision of coming
to florida right yeah for vacation it's
a very good move on her end but there
there is a community here that doesn't
want to now for the other 310 million
people who don't live here a big
majority of those guys are hoping this
guy throws his name in the hat and he
goes out there and competes so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]